做短片其实就两个
一个是游泳
一个是真实
我看好多人
哎呀又是学什么技巧啊又是怎么去表的哎呀
技巧的这个东西呗哎呀就能把你踢来了
那有什么应用什么特色呢
而且那个算法平台稍微一遍
你就没了
然后大家看习惯了以后都煩了
真正有的东西我告诉你就两个一个什么一个是游泳
我就今天你知道都被他什么的我应用
大家都不用说说你行啊就直接在短片那直接送
然后会打开哎呀又直接送
所以你在表达的时候就是
我
什么问题
然后怎么解决
欺负用你平时表达的语言不要搞到那个门座之后呢
为什么因为那个
视频已经可以提训你的门本了
然后人家一问还真好批配就直接推出了
这些相当于什么意思呢我给大家举个例子就好了就是一个一个市场
然后你一订决所有人都按套
好来我们家看一看吧你反复反你见过门这种人你反复反
对吧你最喜欢的法法就是
晚上一挂除了质游给选啥的不会
你看你看人家来这一家
就是人家给你打了个标签
有用
遇到问题早虎隔我啊就多啊好的标签啊
对吧你想想
整个平台拳这好套了哥来我家欠明天一遇
就你真是
而且真是这个就有用这个东西
真是这是有带的有用这个东西是最好复费的
然后带了这个真是而是我特地习惯的事好东西特别喜欢标签
你又没有
你又不是学标签的
你都刚大的空脚值得了你还想标签什么呢
这边话话中啊然后我这个好像好不好
真是是最有用的
你知道这个世界上最棒的资产是什么是信任
信任怎么获得信任真是
毛不愿而敢是最好的方法
就你说话了说错你刚才我说错了对吧我都不见
因为因为这种毛不愿敢是最真实的是最容易获得用户信任的
最好处理你把他扔了
你怎么想的你这个傻子吗你
哈哈哈所以各位
好好思考一下两个事
第1个是
有用
另外一个就是
真是因为有真是如何会获得信任你看你有用的真实让有信任
多好的
我看好多人说
这个
我有流量怎么并线你自己好好想想吧
没啥不好并线呀
要不然要不然你无法获得别人的信任
所以别搞你要花了多少的就两天
有用
真实